We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2 1 9 2.
David P..
I have the rare praise voicemail today.
This is just a beautiful message of uplifting
praise.
Very, very rare.
If you listen to my voicemails, you would
understand just how rare it is.
Take a listen.
Hey, David, this is John from New York.
It's fun to take this time out.
Thank you genuinely for the work you've done
thus far on covering the pandemic crisis and
the very presidents of breathing's in particular.
It's been useful for someone to provide perspective
and even a bit of levity in these dire days
and times.
Yes.
Many thanks.
Keep fighting the good fight and you have
our support.
Beautiful message from John.
That was not a plan.
Just a really it's really great to hear that.
And we've been doing the daily press briefings.
I've been live streaming them and providing
commentary.
There is some debate about whether I should
start skipping the Trump propaganda part at
the meeting beginning.
Just mute that and turn the volume up when
the doctors actually start speaking.
We'll see what people think today on stream.
But yeah, come on down and join me.
Join me for the live streams.
Let me remind you, Thursday, April 9th, we
are going to try to do a membership bomb in
March because people are tightening belts.
It's a bad economic situation.
We had three hundred and eighty nine membership
cancelations in March.
This was the most we've ever had in any month.
OK, so I don't want anybody's last dollar
tight.
Times are tough.
We get it.
But we want to avoid having to, you know,
reduce staffing, reduce hours, any of that
stuff.
We want to keep doing more rather than less.
So to kind of try to fight back against this
Thursday, April 9th, 2:00 p.m. Eastern, 11:00
a.m.
Pacific, an e-mail.
We'll go out to everybody on our mailing list
with a special membership coupon code.
The idea is that day we want to try to recover
as many of these lost members as possible.
So I invite you to sign up for my newsletter.
Sign up today.
David Pakman dot com.
April 9th, you'll get an e-mail with instructions
on how to take advantage of this one day special.
That's the goal.
Get signed up and you'll get access to the
bonus show as a member on today's bonus show.
I will have the latest for you on the producer,
Pat Forde.
Fire.
Fire fighters.
Flood.
Roof collapse.
Fiasco.
That producer Pat.
He's been dealing with.
And I also have optimistic news about Òhat's
upcoming heroic and triumphant return to the
bonus show.
All of that and much more on today's bonus
show.
I'll speak to that.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.